winter is coming and the rains of
castamere now because I'm keeping these
episode review spoiler free this one's
actually going to be really hard for me
to even figure out how to talk about cuz
Wow there have been some shocking and
surprising things happening over the
course of this show but nothing has so
fundamentally changed the landscape of
what was going on like the events of
this episode and it's the kind of shake
up that it could break a lot of other
shows because it makes you it forces you
to really reassess what is this show
even about I had its fundamental core
and for a lot of people are gonna
realize well this story is not what I
thought it was going to be and I think
the show handles that really well in
terms of how everything is presented so
that it becomes as digestible as
something this massive who can be some
of something feel like I can safely talk
about there's some stuff going on around
the wall right now because you've got
the two youngest stark boys along with
their servants you know and they've been
on the run since the end of the second
season earlier in the season they linked
up with some other characters they
didn't talk too much about them cuz I
didn't really care one way or the other
they were there they were fine there was
nothing wrong with them they hadn't
really done a lot yet well we're getting
a better sense of all these groups and
also where some of these characters are
headed and it brings in some magic
llamas in a way that I'm more
comfortable with because it's not tying
them to a specific deity and I kind of
like that you know there's some stuff
going on and we don't really know what
this is right now now I feel like I
can't really talk about the the big set
piece of this show really at all without
giving away really too much you know
even if I eat if I say what characters
are involved or even where it happens I
really feel like that's giving too much
away it's got a you got to go into this
blindly I will say though in terms of
some of the other storylines that went
on in this episode I've come to the
realization I don't care about Jon Snow
which hasn't been a problem yet but I
feel like he's gonna be an increasing
problem as the show goes on because I'm
really getting the feel that he's going
to be
more and more central to the overall
story and he's just boring here's the
thing with Jon Snow he has never
surprised me every single step of his
journey has been completely predictable
I'm not gonna go so far as to say that
when he first showed up I could have
predicted where he is right now but I
can always see the next few steps in his
journey from where he is when we first
meet him we know he's going to a wall
and when he gets there you can already
guess what the net what the dynamic is
gonna be with him and the other members
of the Nights Watch and when he goes
beyond the wall what happens to him
there with egret is also very
predictable there's never been any part
of his story that has ever surprised me
and given a lot of the really amazing
stuff that goes on with other characters
that just makes him really boring and I
don't care it's like I think in an
effort to make him as as Noble as the
story requires him to be it just makes
him dul in a way that Ned Stark never
was Ned Stark was incredibly noble but
he was surrounded by all these people
who weren't and it really made for fun
contrast Jon Snow is working more or
less in isolation he's got other people
around him but because he's so far
removed from everything else going on it
just makes his nobility rather than
being in contrast to those around him
just makes him that guy who's off there
and he's Noble whatever i'm still really
liking what's going on with Daenerys
they've introduced a new character into
her story though that I right now I like
him but if they go the direction that I
think they're going to go with him I'm
gonna end up disliking him pretty
shortly down the road but for right now
he's enjoyable so one more episode to go
I have a feeling is probably gonna be a
slower-paced episode because the way
these seasons have usually gone is the
really big dramatic Oh was always the
second-to-last episode you know the
execution event Stark the Battle of
Blackwater last episode is usually
wrapping things up and just putting
putting them to bed until we can start
up again but until then let me ask you
this which television movie hero have
you found ridiculously boring even
though everything else going on around
him is awesome leave a comment let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned